good morning John it's funny I have also
been worried about AI this week which is
actually not very weird at all because
we have actual intelligences not
artificial ones and thus we are bound to
be anchored to different interests and
worries I wrote a couple of books about
how when new things arrive as they
inevitably do we tend to retreat to our
camps that new thing might be a pandemic
or a large-scale social change or a
really powerful new technology or an
alien it doesn't matter what it is the
more confused we are the more we head to
the place where we feel safest and then
from the safety of that place we think
about the concerns of that place and
then we ask questions specifically about
that concern and then the more powerful
places tend to have their conversations
be the ones that are dominant in the
broader conversation and then eventually
it all bubbles out into there being two
groups that have lots of internal
divisions but mostly are budding with
each other you can watch these groups
starting to Define themselves and
differentiate themselves right now in
real time and it will be probably five
or ten years before we actually know
what questions we're trying to get
answers to and what the kind of of
dominant perspectives on it will be and
I don't know what they're going to be I
don't even know what questions we need
to ask yet I certainly don't know the
answers to those questions like the idea
of these models is they don't copy
things they look at a lot of different
things whether that's text or pictures
they learn how these things are
structured and then they output things
that have that kind of structure but
when they do that sometimes their
procedures make them copy the guys
mid-journey to imagine an Afghani woman
with green eyes and this is what it gave
me mid Journey's model does not contain
this famous image from the 1980s
National Geographic cover but it has
been trained on that image and so it is
plagiarizing it can you sue it for that
is it okay for it to have trained on so
many copyrighted works that didn't agree
to have it train on them should artists
and rights holders be able to opt out of
that training process is any of this a
violation of existing laws or is it a
call for new legislation who will use
this what will it enable who will it
hurt I don't know people are going to
disagree about this stuff like crazy so
here's my big concern John because of
course you got to have one big one
you're gonna have a lot of little ones
but one big one we have not yet gotten
through the last massive revolutionary
shift in human communication we don't
know what to do about last Tuesday yet
we are still actively figuring out how
to be humans and societies with the
current tremendously disruptive tools
that we were given 10 20 years ago we
are just realizing that we live a lot of
our lives in places that are not
democracies that we do not get a vote
where the leadership can change based on
who has enough money to buy the thing
that we live in a lot of these platforms
haven't really ever been through a
recession they've had so much money
they've been able to grow and grow and
now are they at a ceiling and what will
they do to punch through that ceiling
what like we don't know oh that is very
big very disruptive it's been difficult
and now it feels like we're about to
have another tremendously weird entirely
new wrench thrown into the works of
human communication a lot of the things
I see people saying chat GPT is good at
I don't think it is good at like it's
not good at replacing Wikipedia it very
confidently States things that are both
untrue and true and there's no way to
know the difference without fact
checking and I don't think that it has a
good way of figuring that out itself I
don't just don't think it's going to be
good at that but that's a really hard
problem and there are really easy ones
that I think it'll be great at like for
example getting people to dislike each
other more and there are lots of people
who want people to be more afraid of
each other and to dislike each other
more both external and internal like a
lot of the get out the vote measures is
about getting people to be more afraid
and angry and getting people to be
afraid and mad at each other very easy
like trivial problem for an AI like this
to solve all you have to do is emulate a
human in its worst moments and in our
worst moments we are not complex we have
not figured out how to be a society
inside of the current Communications
Revolution and while people and
societies can and will change very fast
it's usually not fun I for one wouldn't
mind if things got a little less
interesting for a little while but we
don't get to choose these things
John I'll see you on Tuesday